they could take away our cars like that
no [ __ ] driving you know this is what
i'm scared of this is what i'm scared of
hey when i hear elon musk talking about
he's on our side you think he's team
lockdown okay there's team lockdown and
then there's team freedom
you would think he hangs out i mean he's
part of that team lockdown
no no no no no he's gonna move to finish
let me just finish
i'm sorry let me just team lockdown
it appears to me i mean he claimed he
got a car into space
anyways okay so whatever well that's
another
hour but anyways what i'm saying is when
he starts talking [ __ ] i write
he's nuts hold on man when he was on
your podcast
and he said the things he said about the
lockdown and tyranny and all that
at first i was like [ __ ] yeah elon's
[ __ ] let me
let me help you out let me finish though
let me just finish 30 seconds we get
back to tits
just give me 30. i'm just trying to
finish this point man there's a point to
this okay
um so elon musk now he's he's like
he's like it seems like he's on team
freedom holy [ __ ] that's that's if
that's real
that's beautiful but my conspiratory
mind
would think like what if i don't know
these are just conclusions don't make
fun of me
but this would be a great idea for team
lockdown if team lockdown said how do we
keep
lockdown going say hey check this out
elon you're going to
pretend you're a rebel jesus hold on
this is just
a conspiracy it's a movie this is not
true i hope this is not true
i hope he's the gym i hope he's legit
okay i'm praying that he's legit
okay i'm i pray so but what about this
team lockdown tells elon hey listen
be a rebel control the opposition be a
rebel say you're just gonna open up your
plan
and then we say [ __ ] a thousand
corona deaths and then we
restart the lockdown because and then
then now everyone's afraid
to step up like elon musk crazy that
thought is that someone would ever get
together and conspire to do that to
control people
right now that's what i was just talking
about 15 minutes ago
we're in the new world you're derailing
you're derailing the car
you're i try to help you out you don't
think that's interesting
you don't think that that's interesting
that's interesting i'm into it what if
he opens this plant and then there's all
this karana i think you're wrong
i think you're right i think you're
right hope i'm wrong i think he's the
captain of team freedom
i hope i'm wrong you you got to listen
to his words and see what his actions
are
he again had a deceit going on eddie
against
the government of california opened up
his plan
since day one he said if you're gonna
arrest someone arrest me if you think
that this is some
three-way game it's ridiculous the guy
invests all
his own money in his businesses
i thought he got like you get some
subsidies for these millions
millions but that's also the most think
about
who who's who on the planet is more
innovative than that guy
the guy's doing crazy [ __ ] man he's
freedom
in order to do three or four different
realms he's
digging tunnels to vegas he's shooting
rockets into space
he's making the these most insane
electric cars look i've talked to the
guy a few times
he's eddie bravo he's a [ __ ] super
genius they exist
i hope and that's what he is i'm not
saying he's not a genius
i just hope he's on i hope he's really
on team freedom i hope that's real he's
rick from rick and morty i feel good
that you tell me this is all of his
worldly possessions he's selling
all of his houses and you know why so
people can't talk should go oh you live
like that but
you live there you own this he's like
he's gonna help he's legit i hope he's
on team freedom a billion dollars
i hope i'm wrong is he is he moving is
he moving to texas
he's gonna move one of his plans no he's
not anymore because they're not because
they bet they back they bent the knee
they to take triple c's thing they bent
the knee to him
man he's opening up now because he went
you want to do that i'm the [ __ ] out
here they're like whoa
okay you can have some people but not
all people you went all right we'll stay